what is an arithmetic sequence well
basically what a sequence is it's a list
okay so it's a list of values or numbers
and there's two different things going
on here that you want to pay attention
to one is the term number so you can see
I have listed N equals 1 N equals 2 N
equals 3 that's the term that you're on
and then there is a sub 1 a sub 2 a sub
3 and so on and that represents the
value of that term so it's kind of like
a batting order like say somebody's
batting third but who is that oh it's Jo
for example right so that's the term but
this is the value of the term okay now
when we go to find a specific term in
the sequence what we can do is we can
write two different types of formulas
one is an explicit formula which will
take you right to that term that you
want so if you want the hundredth term
you put in N equals 100 it'll take you
right to the hundreds of term and then
there's another type of formula it's
called a recursive formula where you
have to keep repeating to get to the
next term the next term the next term so
for example for this one right here if
we were to write a recursive formula
what we're going to do is we're going to
start off by saying a sub 1 okay which
is our first term - and then a sub n
okay this is the nth term you're gonna
take that a sub n minus 1 okay so n
minus 1 just means that you're gonna go
if you want this term you go to the
previous term plus D okay and this is
when n is greater than or equal to 2
meaning the second term third term
fourth term now what does a D well D is
called the common difference okay and
when you're going from 2 to 5 5 to 8 8
to 11 by taking this number and
subtracting the number before it you get
that common difference so 11 minus 8 is
3 14 minus 11 is 3 so you can see we're
consistently adding 3 each time to get
to the next term that's what makes us an
arithmetic sequence if you were
multiplying then that's a geometric
sequence we'll talk about that in
another video so in this video what
we're talking about is adding in this
particular example we're adding 3 so
what I'm going to do is instead of
having D here
replace that with a common difference of
three and the way this works is say we
want to find out the one two three four
five six term okay so what you would do
so here is N equals six if we want to
find a sub six we go to the a sub six
minus one okay which is going to be the
fifth term which is the one before it
and we're going to add three and that's
going to take us to seventeen now if we
wanted to find the hundredth term we'd
have to keep going to the previous term
adding three and going to the previous
term adding three would take a long time
for us for a computer would be really
quick but what's going to work a little
bit better here is if we write an
explicit formula and that's what this
one here shows us so a sub 1 is the
first term so in this case that's two
then we're adding three each time that's
D the common difference and minus one
times okay now why n minus one well if
you want to find the seventh term and
you're already at the first term you
have to add three once twice three times
four times five times six times so even
though it's the seventh term we're only
adding three six times two two so that's
why it's n minus one it just takes one
less addition of the common difference
to get to the turn that you want so if
we can simplify this down a little bit
further this is going to be two plus
three and minus three which equals three
and minus one so there we go now if you
want to find the 100th term all we have
to do is put in a hundred for n that's
three hundred minus one is two 99 or if
you want the tenth term that's thirty
minus one which is 29 okay so this is
working with arithmetic sequences okay I
want to show you another example a bit
more challenging example and that's this
one over here a sub 3 equals 5 a sub 6
equals 26 how do you find a sub 10 which
is a 10th term well before we get into
that I want to show you what these ones
right here if we were to graph these can
I make a little grid here when N equals
1 see how the value of the term is
so I'm just going to plot that right
there when N equals two yeah output or
the value of the term is five okay if n
is three we're up here at eight okay and
what you can notice is that this is
forming a straight line it's linear and
when you look at this equation here you
can tell by looking at it okay three is
really like our slope we're going up 3
over 1 up 3 over 1 that's the common
difference is really the slope and then
the y-intercept negative 1 okay is where
it's crossing the y-axis here okay so
you can see the parallels between
arithmetic sequences and linear
equations so let's go over to this one
now and what we're going to do is
instead of thinking this has two points
in our sequence we're going to write
these as coordinates we're gonna say 3
comma 5 and 6 comma 26 okay and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
find the slope so 26 minus 5 which is 21
6 minus 3 which is 3 and so you can see
we have a slope of 7 okay so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go y equals
7x plus B so I'm just treating this like
two points finding the equation of a
line and to find that B value we're just
going to put in one of these points so
when X is 3 y is 5 3 is the input 5 is
the output so 5 equals 7 times 3 plus B
so 5 equals 21 plus B subtract the 21
and B equals negative 16 we're gonna put
that back in for B and we've got y
equals 7x minus 16 now instead of
writing it like the equation of a line
I'm going to write it using the sequence
notations a sub N equals 7 n minus 16 so
you can see if we put 3 in 7 times 3 is
21 minus 16 gives us back the value of
that third term which is 5 but if you
want to find the 10th term now we put in
10 that's 70 minus 16 which is 54 so
this is going to be 54
so this is a one-way to work with it
just work with it as two data points
think of the equation of a line there's
another way to do it too and that's
where you can actually write a system of
equations so we're going to use this
explicit formula here okay and we're
going to write two equations using a sub
N and N and then we can solve for a 1
and D I'll show you what I mean so let
me erase this to give us a little more
space so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna say a sub N equals a sub 1 plus D
times n minus 1 and when this value is 5
3 minus 1 since this is the third term
this will be 2 and for this one 26 we
don't know the first term but 6 minus 1
is 5 and so now what you can see is we
have a system of equations and we can
solve for a 1 and D by subtracting or
doing the substitution method then we
can go ahead and put those back in and
we'll have an explicit formula to find
any term so this is how you work with
arithmetic sequences go ahead and check
out some of my other videos about
arithmetic series how to find the sum of
a sequence of numbers it's called a
series and the geometric ones where
you're multiplying to get to the next
term if you're enjoying these videos go
ahead and subscribe to the channel and I
look forward to seeing you in the other
videos